[музика]
Щиро вітаємо Ми раді що ви дивитесь нашу
програму У фокусі Європа наслідки
путінської війни впливають також на
російське Мистецьке та музичне
середовище це стосується навіть
знаменитостей із мільйонною аудиторією
дедалі більше артистів зокрема російські
ГУР та Лоя Вера які публічно критикує
війну в Україні стають мішені російської
влади іншим як от співачці Світлані
лободі виступати в Росії більше не
дозволяють
тим часом існує навіть спеціально
створена комісія з розкриття так званих
антиросійських дій серед митців тому
багатьом музикантам добре знайоме
відчуття коли після концерту приїжджає
російська спецслужба кожен хто має
велику аудиторію як от співачка Світлана
Лобода природно викликає своїм посланням
проти війни багато шуму і тим
енергійніше вживає заходів проти них
російська влада часто єдиним виходом
залишається Втеча за кордон
море вогнів у Ризі столиці Латвії
глядачі гостинно приймають співачку
Світлану лободу і вона знаходить чіткі
слова
[оплески]
Добрий вечір друзі в моїй країні і де
велика жахлива несправедлива війна
[музика]
з собою
Світлана Лобода роками жила у Москві і
має у Росії мільйони шанувальників
Однак наприкінці лютого вона публічно
засудила російську загарбницьку війну
проти України та відвернулась від Росії
Я хочу бути на боці світла на боці добра
на боці правди
відповідь Москви не забарилася Лобода
отримала заборону на в'їзд до Росії на
50 років
співачка є лише одним із прикладів того
як у Росії грають знаменитостей за
публічні виступи проти політики Кремля
артисти актори та телеведучі вимушені
залишити країну
той хто залишився ризикує стати жертвою
переслідувань з боку влади зокрема гурт
алоє вера із
[музика]
єкатеринбургасцефалія што далі та в залі
перечитали пальці руки ноги целый берём
їхнє солістка Віра мусеїлян була
одружена з відомим російським
опозиційним політиком який зараз
перебуває під вартою за відверту
антивоєнну позицію
вона сама теж протестує проти політики
Кремля і це має певні наслідки
наші концерти забороняють нас раптово
вилучають із фестивалів
це відбувається дуже несподівано буває
що нам телефонують Буквально за кілька
годин до концерту і кажуть що нам
заборонено його проводити і чим
серйозніша політична ситуація в Росії
тим відкритіше влада забороняє концерт
[музика]
Але група не здається вони організували
концерт у таємному місці для обраних
людей у санкт-петербурзі
[музика]
за словами вокалістки віри усе ілян тоді
до організаторів завітали із ФСБ
вони вимагали надати записи камер
спостереження та фотографії щоб
ідентифікувати людей які були на
концерті
ми самі а те як ми живемо про що
говоримо які публікуємо пости у
соцмережах усе це вже є причина щоб
забороняти нас я не приховую те що ми
ходили на мітинги ми намагались
висловлювати свою громадянську позицію
як могли і цього вже зараз достатньо щоб
тебе не підпускали до твоєї діяльності
офіційно поки що чорного списку немає
але у ЗМІ з'являються імена артистів чиї
виступи небажані
зараз російський парламент робить ще
один крок і хоче карати державних
службовців які запрошують цих артистів
серед них навіть керівник першого
російського каналу і директор
знаменитого Великого театру у Москві
ці державні службовці перебувають на
неправильному боці історії
наше завдання повернути їм здоровий
глузд
якщо ти державний службовець то не можеш
виплачувати державні гроші поп зіркам і
знаменитостям які відкритою публічно
займають антиросійську позицію
приємною антиросийскую позицию
Світлана Лобода переконана що обрала
правильний бік вона дякує своїм
шанувальникам у Європі за підтримку
А якщо до її шанувальників у Росії
Росія - це країна що заблукала сьогодні
очень заблудилась а тому що її очолює
Людина яка веде цю країну в
неправильному напрямку
і поки Люди там цього не зрозуміють
нічого хорошого в цій країні не буде
І до того часу такі виступи будуть
можливі лише за кордоном а не в Росії
війна Росії в Україні продовжується З
усією жорстокістю вона означає життя в
умовах надзвичайного стану передусім для
людини неподалік від лінії фронту
зокрема в регіоні навколо мільйонного
міста Харкова населення там не лише
постійно загрожує смертельно небезпека
там узагалі важко підтримувати
повсякденне життя те що воно все що
існує слід завдячувати таким людям як
листоноша Зоя Гарбузова
той хто перебуває в морі насправді радіє
коли йому щастить побачити китів але
Уявіть що налаштован раптом напала така
гігантська косатка ви у відкритому морі
не знаєте як відлякати тваринок біля
Атлантичного узбережжя Іспанії Все
частіше трапляються напади косаток на
вітрильній яхти спортивні або рибальські
човни морські біологи з пантеличині
мить потрясіння мабуть для кожного
моряка кілька тонна косатка таранить
човен біля берегів Іспанії
тварина має достатньо сил щоб пошкодити
вітрильну яхту або у найгіршому випадку
перекинути її
це сцени які йому теж не зрозумілі
Рафаель Мартінес плаває у морі із
дружиною уже 30 років поспіль
ніщо не може так швидко вивести із
рівноваги подружжя з кадіса але зустріч
з косатками на жахала їх
раптом я відчув поштовх
що він розвернувся на 180 градусів
попрямував на північ у цю мить Моя
дружина помітила косаток Я в першу чергу
зв'язався з береговою охороною Та
попросив про допомогу
адже коли така велика тварина атакують
від човен і ти не знаєш як довго це буде
тривати То може статися все що завгодно
на іспанському та португальському
Атлантичному узбережжі росте страх за
останні два роки експерти зафіксували
понад 300 інцидентів
наразі іспанський береговій охороні
доводиться Майже щодня рятувати людей
які потрапили у біду бо їхні човен
пошкодили косатки про це нам
розповідають моряки
Екіпаж цього човна також зміг
зафільмувати драматичні сцени
хижаки вага яких може досягати семи тонн
штовхають яхту як іграшку з одного борту
в інший
чотири посадки мітили передусім у стерно
кожного разу коли Я переходжу на один
бік він іде на інший морські ссавці
крутяться біля човна майже дві години
вчені обережно говорять про взаємодію
між тваринами яким загрожує вимирання
але для Рафаеля мартінеса та більшості
моряків на вітрильних човнах - це напади
в якусь миті відчув паніку
косатки були зайняті вже 15 хвилин і
раптом я бачу як позаду нас пливе шматок
Стерна
без стельна човном неможливо керувати
великі питання Чому тварини це роблять
їм щось заподіяли
щось їх повністю дестабілізувало
я бачила наче вони були абсолютно
божевільними
у порту коніль de la Frontera
конкуренція за їжу робить кусаток
агресивними кажуть багато місцевих
жителів
на блакитного тунця полюють як морські
хижаки так і рибалки
усуперечці за здобич рибалки могли
поранити косаток гарпунами стверджують
зоозахисники у рибалок інша теорія
Ми думаємо що один вітрильник міг
випадково поранити дитинча косатки
і тому тварини Зараз атакують нижче
човнів
такого раніше ніколи не було
дослідник китів езекіль андреу не хоче
використовувати слово напад за його
оцінками залишилося лише 40 іберійських
косаток тому їхній захист є пріоритетом
дуже важко з'ясувати причини адже
косатки нам цього не скажуть
але ми можемо за соку ймовірність
говорити про те що всі ці взаємодії
пов'язані з людиною
ми вважаємо що ця поведінка набута
і вона передається решті групи
таких відповідей більшості морякам на
човнах недостатньо вони звинувачують
вчених і владу у недостатній увазі до
їхньої безпеки
Рафаель Мартінес вважає що за тваринами
слід стежити за допомогою GPS
передавачів якщо нічого не відбудеться
він побоюється що деякі кермувальники в
екстреній ситуації можуть взятися за
зброю якщо твій човен не твоє життя в
небезпеці Тоді ти захищаєшся мені шкода
косаток але якщо мова йде про їхнє життя
чи про моє То я віддаю перевагу своєму
втім так далеко це зайти не повинно Тому
нам потрібні дослідження та розв'язання
цієї проблеми
подружжя однозначно хоче продовжувати
плавати і лише однієї ситуації Вони
хотіли б уникнути будь-якою ціною новою
зустрічей запорізькими косатками
посушливе літо залишає свої сліди майже
скрізью Європі особливо потерпає
сільське господарство урожай знаходиться
під загрозою у багатьох регіонах
континенту зокрема і в Німеччині у Землі
саксонія на сході країни де росте
насправді багато зернових надзвичайно
сухо також і на полях фермера юнаса
Шульца ніхофа він боїться подальшої
посухи в найближчі роки і вже
зосереджується на рослинах які краща її
витримають
красиві зерна кіно
Вони мають гарний світлий колір гарний
розмір і коли ти їх кусаєш то вони
досить тверді це означає що настав час
для обмолоту кіно нова рослина на полях
Йона сашульце ніхофа органічний фермер
любить випробовувати щось нове коли 8
років тому Він успадкував ферму свого
батька на його землі росли спельта овес
картопля та кукурудза чорний родючий
ґрунт макдебурзького бйорди тобто
родючою рівнини вважається особливо
багатим на поживні речовини
у нас тут стало дуже сухо набагато
сухіше і ми більше не збираємось тільки
зерна як раніше
щоб забезпечити своє існування фермер
експериментує з кіно стародавньої
зерновою культурою інків яка походить із
Південної Америки її батьківщиною є анти
зараз мова йде не лише про економіку
сьогодення але й про економіку завтра
післязавтра та навіть через три роки і
якщо я беруться за основу то повинен
щось випробувати це частина
підприємницької діяльності ризикувати
іноді вигравати А іноді програвати і
фокус полягає у тому щоб більше виграти
ніж програти
Спочатку він просто вчиться в цьому де
взагалі купувати насіння коли його сіяти
коли можна збирати врожай кіно навчання
на практиці після 6 років поступово
набирає обертів що це ніхов є винятком у
своєму регіоні на північному сході
Німеччини Привіт
юнасе Ще не агрономка уртеґау-вінкель
також переконана що сільське
господарство Німеччини має реагувати на
зміни клімату тому вона звернулась до
органічного фермера
Я вважаю що ми достатньо говорили
достатньо політезували і достатньо
задумувались над тим як це може бути На
мою думку ми повинні перейти до дій
разом Вони вимірюють вологість ґрунту на
полі Шульца ніхофа
навіть видно який він Сухий
3,1
менше ніж 10%. це замало для спельти
вівса чи пшениці які зазвичай ростуть на
цих ґрунтах Так тут настільки сухо Що
Мабуть справді слід задуматися над тим
щоб відмовитись від зерна та посадити
наприклад нут оскільки він імовірно
витримує посуху подивимось
поки що фермер вирощує кіно а лише на
двох із половиною відсотках площі
спельта та картопля досі залишаються
його основним джерелом доходу
однак четверте місце тим часом займає
рослина що походить із субтропічних
регіонів нут
Ого яка гаряча земля Нічого собі завдяки
своїм перстем листкам він мав би явно
перевагу у боротьбі з посухою
тут можна збирати росу яка випала за ніч
геть коли зовсім сухо тут усе ще
зберігається невелика вологість
до того ж коренева система ноту дуже
глибока
фермершується нігофа задоволений урожаєм
кіно а завдяки високим температурам
зерно цього року висохло значно швидше
ніж зазвичай занадто сухе дозріло
а врожай класичних зернових був майже на
20% менше ще одна ознака того що він на
правильному шляху
Я відчуваю потребу розвиватися далі світ
постійно змінюється І тому ми повинні
змінюватися разом із ним
з огляду на посуху що з кожним роком
лише зростає каже органічний фермер
перехід на інші види рослин у Німеччині
неминучий і в цьому він хоче бути одним
із перших
оскільки зараз дещо випало з ритму
зокрема клімат як Ми щойно бачили одне
місто у Швейцарії робить ставку на
відпочинок у воєму з готелі як
альтернативу відпочинку в ідеальному
світі о кантонні валє більше не йде мова
про звичайну програму як отмилуватись
горами чи відволікатись від буднів зараз
тут є пропозиція для безстрашних без
приватності Зате на повітрі з
гарантовано коротким сном але завеликі
гроші звучить спокусливо чи ні
наче з неба впало ліжко прямо на
головній вулиці шум автомобілів вихлопні
гази зростання цін на бензин вони не
проти якщо їхні гості не спатимуть анти
і делічний номер 0 зірок останній проект
братів близнюків ріквін їхня мистецтва
як вони самі кажуть візуальні помилки
які пробуджують ламають укорінені звички
та структури
зараз не час щоб спати
Ми повинні реагувати на актуальну
ситуацію у світі
[музика]
зробити відчутною антиідилєю на заправці
символ світу що заплутався війна в
Європі енергетична криза інфляція
як ми ці Ми також відчуваємо
відповідальність Щоб зробити щось самим
адже ми можемо займатися не лише
естетикою Ми помітили що суспільство є
прагнення до пробудження і воно дуже і
дуже велике
у 2008 році вони запустили першу
беззіркову версію в ядерному бункері а
потім медичні ліжка просто неба на
виноградниках та на альпійських луках
спільне для всіх версій наявність
прислуги у реальному житті Вони працюють
у банку пекарні або ще навчаються зверху
вони носять уніформу А внизу їхня
особистість може сяяти яскравими
кольорами заправляння ліжка подача
сніданку спілкування з гостями і як
Прислуга вони є важливою частиною
концепції все для того щоб я могла
приносити гостям задоволення і мені теж
приємно Звісно що це і є моєю метою але
передусім налаштувати гостей на позитив
понад 20 років Вони створюють мистецтво
яке втручається в реальність вийдіть із
музею і зануртесь у повсякденне життя
майже 330 євро щоб переночувати в готелі
0-зірок який суперечить класичному
образу готелів
як на мене це інвестицію власну
саморефлексію тож якщо хтось визнає
цінність особисто для себе то 325
Франків це Ніщо я б сказав що це навіть
дешево він міг би заощадити собі можливо
ще на один курс чи тренінг
у світі де багато речей більше не
поєднуються перебувати в цьому ліжку є
заявою воно стоятиме в цьому місці ще до
середини вересня але що буде далі у
братів близнюків вже є нові ідеї
Привіт Володимир
чуєш ми проводимо телефонну конференцію
як от бути коли йде дощ зараз я про це
вже не спитаю у будь-якому випадку ми
бажаємо вам добре провести час і
спокійних начей Дякуємо що дивились нашу
програму У фокусі Європа то наступної
зустрічі
українською мовою озвучено центром медіа
ініціатив переклад Володимира та Олеся
Швед режисер Павло Тимченко текст читали
Олена потоцька Юрій Лисенко та Олесь
гоян Київ 2022 рік
[музика]